la fête de la musique célébrée partout
en france créée en 1982 puis elle a fait
école dans le monde entier dès la fin
d'après midi les artistes ont investi
les rues les places et les scènes de
plein air ambiance entre vincennes et
paris coumba canet mathiot ville et dire
qu'à l'origine la fête de la musique ne
devait durer que trente petites minutes
27 ans après c'est devenu une véritable
tradition chaque année près de 15
millions de français se retrouvent dans
la rue en famille ou entre amis on
chante on danse
chacun a ses raisons de participer à la
fête
mieux
c'est une obligation légale on est
obligé on n'a pas le choix une fois par
an la loi nous fait obligation de faire
sa fête à la musique
et comme nous sommes un groupe citoyen
nous optons perd on sait tous que c'est
une formidable que ça existe partout il
ya des ouïes des événements gratuits
comme ça la musique assez variés mais la
fête de la musique c'est aussi un
tremplin une occasion de se faire
remarquer les maisons de disques profite
de l'événement pour présenter leurs
nouveaux talents ici au château de
vincennes des artistes peu connus jouer
au milieu de chanteurs célèbres magath
chante depuis plus de quinze ans et ce
soir il a partagé l'affiché avec des
artistes comme thomas dutronc
pour rappel l'année dernière j'étais
dans le 5e arrondissement en bas de la
fac de médecine
en face d'un bar
et je joue avec ma guitare tout seul
voilà et aujourd'hui je touche 80 c'est
donc c'est pas mal c'est pour beaucoup
dans la porte de la musique rappelle
aussi des souvenirs
j'ai passé aussi des fêtes de la musique
à bosser donc à jouer pardon j'ai aussi
passé des fêtes de la musique chez moi à
m'écouter plein de disques attentivement
avec des bonnes bouteilles et plein de
copains puis on se passait on se faisait
découvrir des morceaux les uns les
autres c'est assez agréable de plein de
styles différents
cette année cette fête populaire a
franchi les portes de certains bâtiments
publics comme ici au ministère de
l'outre-mer
vingt mille concerts sont prévus dans
toute la france la nuit la plus courte
de l'année pourrait être très longue
pour les mélomanes